Dans le chapitre 5 des Galates, la thèse principale de toute la lettre arrive à son application ou ses implications pratiques.
Par là, nous nous rappelons de l'importance que, au lieu de faire des appels très vite au changement des comportements, nous puissions comprendre ce phénomène glorieux qui est la conversion.
Nous ne sommes pas appelés, lorsqu'on va faire par exemple l'évangélisation, à avoir un abordage moraliste envers les personnes, faire des menaces, de l'enfer, dans l'espoir qu'en redressant leur vie, les personnes puissent conquérir leur salut.
Nous savons que les personnes ne manquent pas d'une connaissance de ce qu'ils devraient faire.
Ils ont une conscience qui les accuse constamment comme c'était pour nous avant la conversion.
Donc les manques de l'humanité n'est pas forcément la connaissance de la loi.
Une connaissance plus profonde, plus détaillée de la loi nous rend davantage conscients de combien condamnés nous sommes.
Mais ce qui manque à l'humanité n'est pas la connaissance de ce qu'on devrait faire.
L'obligation de vivre une vie d'amour constamment est vrai amour.
Mais c'est le manque de pouvoir, manque de puissance pour vivre à la hauteur du but de notre existence.
Et donc l'apôtre Paul n'a pas un abordage moraliste envers les Galates.
Sa thèse principale, car la crise des Galates, c'est la corruption de la compréhension du phénomène de la conversion des Galates.
Car les moments où Paul vient et prêche Christ et qu'est Christ crucifié, les Galates sont convertis,
les Saint-Esprit viennent les habiter et ils commencent une bonne marche chrétienne sans aucune connaissance nécessaire de l'arrière-plan juif.
Car Paul a prêché Christ crucifié.
Et c'était suffisant.
Les Galates étaient convertis, ils ont commencé bien la bonne course.
Une corruption doctrinaire a eu lieu.
Les judaïsants sont arrivés.
Ceux qui disaient avoir été convertis par Christ, avoir reconnu Christ comme les vrais Messie,
mais qui voulaient restaurer la base des relations avec Dieu,
ou qui voulaient garder la base des relations avec Dieu,
comme si c'était la loi, les dates, la circoncision,
ce qui marquait plutôt l'ancienne alliance avec les ombres qui pointaient envers Christ.
Une fois que le soleil est arrivé, ces ombres ont perdu leur sens.
Elles sont très utiles pour qu'on soit davantage conscient de toute la richesse de Christ.
Donc l'Ancien Testament, que ce soit clair, reste paroles inspirées,
très puissantes pour continuer à nous faire comprendre mieux les Christ,
la foi et pour booster notre sanctification.
C'est les mêmes dieux qui parlent dans l'Ancien Testament et le Nouveau Testament.
Nous ne voulons mépriser aucune portion des Écritures.
mais la base des relations, une fois que le soleil arrive,
elle change de manière substantielle,
de manière plutôt en termes d'intensité,
en termes de liberté.
Et donc dans les Nouveaux Testaments,
dans la Nouvelle Alliance,
Christ suffit pour être pour nous les modèles de vivre une vie qui glorifie Dieu.
et il nous donne cette liberté de la coupabilité que la loi pourrait provoquer
et la puissance aussi pour mener une vie progressive de conformité avec Jésus
qui est naturellement et automatiquement une vie de conformité avec la loi.
Paul est en train de parler en termes de fruits de l'esprit.
Il n'est pas en train de parler en termes des lois,
d'obéissance à la loi.
Il est en train de dire, contre ces choses, il n'y a pas de loi.
Donc toute la loi cherchait des manières détaillées
à nous communiquer quelque chose qui à la fin des comptes était la vie de Dieu lui-même,
la vie du Christ lui-même,
cette vie d'amour pour Dieu qui glorifie Dieu
et qui naturellement accomplit parfaitement la loi.
Si nous manifestons les fruits de l'esprit,
nous serons automatiquement en train d'accomplir la loi,
les vrais buts de la loi.
Et donc Paul, il va corriger d'abord la doctrine,
la compréhension de comment les personnes sont sauvées,
pour faire des applications ou implications
afin de régler les problèmes concrets ou tangibles.
Car dans cette communauté,
qui a commencé dans une bonne unité,
certains disaient dès le départ,
Christ me suffit, je suis fils des dieux,
je suis délivré de mon esclavage aux œuvres de la chair,
même si je ne connaissais pas la loi,
mais je connaissais très bien ce qui était mes passions pécheresses.
Christ est suffisant pour moi,
l'apôtre Paul a prêché cette pureté,
je ne vais bouger aucun centimètre
envers une autre compréhension de l'Évangile.
D'autres étaient plus pliés à la corruption judaïsante.
Je pense qu'il faut quand même nous circoncire.
Je pense que c'est de progresser en maturité,
de restaurer les éléments de l'Ancien Testament.
On va mettre les manières d'Israël dans les cultes,
on va faire la réproduction de l'âge de l'Alliance,
on va mener un rapport envers l'attente
des bénédictions envers Dieu sur notre performance.
Il faut qu'on garde la persévérance
dans les campagnes des 70 semaines
pour qu'on puisse être béni.
Peut-être qu'on doit aussi se préoccuper
à limiter la manière dont on va s'habiller.
Peut-être que, comme on voit les votes des nazis réens
dans l'Ancien Testament,
peut-être que c'est bien de ne pas toucher aux cheveux.
Et on commence à restaurer cette relation avec Dieu
dont les bénédictions peuvent dépendre
de notre comportement.
sous les risques même
de perdre les saluts.
Et donc ces hérésies étaient embrassées
par un groupe de l'Église.
Et dans un autre extrême,
il y avait un petit groupe
qui était plutôt dans cette direction.
Ces personnes sont folles.
Nous avons tous été affranchis
de la vie hyper-religieuse.
La vie qui cherchait à embrasser
tous les types de religions
qu'elles soient païennes ou juifs,
mais dont nos sacrifices
et notre performance
étaient les grands responsables
d'être bénis par Dieu.
On était esclaves des religions.
On était esclaves des péchés.
Et pour compenser les péchés,
on était esclaves des religions.
mais si j'ai bien compris l'Évangile,
Christ a tout fait pour moi
et donc maintenant,
je peux me plonger dans les péchés
car Dieu est gracieux,
faire usage de notre liberté
pour donner occasion à la chair à nouveau.
Troisième groupe.
Donc, ces trois positions au sein de l'Église
sont devenues
des moyens
pour qu'une vraie division et bataille
aient lieu au sein de cette Église.
Paul était en train de dire
« Vous êtes en train de vous mordre
et vous dévorez ».
Ce qu'il peut le faire,
c'est de corriger la doctrine.
Donc, si une personne pense
pouvoir accomplir parfaitement
les moindres commandements,
elle devrait être obligée
à accomplir tous les commandements
et les saluts devraient défendre d'elle.
Car si nous avions la possibilité
d'accomplir parfaitement
les moindres commandements,
on aurait pu accomplir
tous les commandements.
Et donc, ça serait vent de la part de Dieu,
folle de la part de Dieu,
méchant de la part de Dieu
d'envoyer son Fils.
Pour mourir pour une race
qui pourrait se sauver.
Donc, Paul va dire
« Je n'annule pas la grâce de Dieu. »
Car si les saluts se donnent par la loi,
Christ est mort en vente.
Et il va insister sur le fait
que comme Christ a tout accompli
en termes de régler
notre problème devant Dieu,
nous avons été pleinement adoptés
en tant qu'enfants des dieux.
Nous sommes greffés à Christ.
Nous sommes unis à Christ.
C'est impossible
pour ceux qui sont véritablement
unis à Christ par la foi,
recevoir un traitement
de la part des dieux
qui puisse dépendre
de notre comportement
vers le salut.
C'est clair qu'en tant qu'il est père,
il peut bien sûr
nous corriger
à fond de nous sauver.
Mais l'attitude paternelle,
même à travers la discipline,
n'est jamais comparable
à l'attitude
d'un tyran
très intéressé
à nous prendre dans une faute
pour nous virer de la famille.
La distinction qu'il peut le faire,
c'est esclave ou fils.
Les esclaves transgressent
et peuvent être virés.
Les enfants transgressent
et par amour
sont disciplinés et corrigés.
Mais jamais,
jamais perdre le salut.
car tout dépend
de l'efficacité
de l'œuvre du Christ.
Et si nous doutons
que l'œuvre du Christ
a été efficace,
que Christ a été parfait,
nous doutons
de l'efficacité
de son salut envers nous.
Et donc,
Paul est en train
de parler
des justifications.
Une justification
qui change complètement
notre position
devant Dieu,
c'est-à-dire
à cause de la justice
parfaite du Christ
substitutive.
Je suis d'une fois
pour toutes
pardonné
et adopté.
Et rien ne peut changer
cette condition
ou cette position
devant Dieu.
Ça passe par
la compréhension
de l'Évangile,
l'œuvre parfaite du Christ
à ma place,
la mort du Christ
à la croix
à ma place.
Et donc,
par mon association
par la foi,
il m'écrédite
son obéissance parfaite
et sa punition parfaite.
Et d'une fois pour toutes,
je peux me présenter
devant Dieu
un Christ
couvert du Christ
et l'attitude
ou les traitements
des dieux envers moi
ne sera plus jamais
autre chose
que la relation
d'un père
envers un enfant
parfaitement récent.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Par contre,
cette union
légale
avec Christ,
elle produit,
car c'est ça
l'objectif
des dieux
en tout ça,
elle produit
une union aussi
vitale
avec Christ.
nous ne sommes pas
en train d'embrasser
Christ comme notre
représentant légal
devant Dieu
de manière
désaffectionnée.
Nous nous sommes
organiquement greffés
à Christ
comme la vigne,
la plante
pour une nouvelle vie.
Et donc,
nous étions des branches
mortes
qui sont greffées
à cette vigne
vivante,
vivifiante
et la sève
ou le Saint-Esprit
qui passe par Christ
commence à manifester
la vie du Christ
dans nos corps
mortels,
dans nos membres.
Et les chrétiens
donc,
peuvent attester
et constater
qu'il était
véritablement pardonné
par Dieu
et adopté par Dieu
lorsqu'ils voient
progressivement
les traits
des dieux,
les caractéristiques
des dieux
s'est manifestant
progressivement
sa vie.
Je peux me considérer
un enfant des dieux
car je vois
des similarités
radicales
entre la vie
que Dieu vit
et ma vie.
Donc,
la solution
qui porte l'apôtre Paul
ne passe pas
par ce qu'on devrait faire
pour corriger
toute cette confusion
que l'Église des Galates
était en train de vivre.
Ça passe par un rappel
et une auto-évaluation
des
la compréhension
de ce qui était
le phénomène
de notre conversion,
de notre nouvelle essence,
de notre justification
et un rappel
donc de notre nouvelle nature.
Donc,
si
vous êtes
véritablement
un Christ,
si l'esprit
de Christ
habite en vous,
si vous êtes
greffé à Christ,
il y a
une puissance
prédominante
en vous
qui vous conduira
progressivement
à manifester
la vie du Christ
dans vos vies.
Il faut faire un rappel
de ce qui caractérisait
notre vie
quand on était
esclave du péché
de la loi,
les œuvres de la chair
pour nous rappeler
ces choses
pour plus qu'ils
se restent
soient encore
en train de vous tenter.
ceux qui sont
en vous
qui sont
déjà crucifiés
la chair
avec ses passions
d'une fois
pour toutes.
Ce qui caractérise
les nouveau-nés
de manière radicale
et prédominante,
c'est que nous avons
tous donné déjà
un coup mortel
à ces passions
charnelles.
C'est-à-dire,
même si elles peuvent
encore se manifester,
elles n'ont pas
la même force,
elles sont en train
de mourir
que ceux qui aspirent
et désirent
notre nouvelle nature
couplés
à la puissance
de Dieu
Tout-Puissant,
troisième personne
de la Trinité,
les Saint-Esprits
qui habitent en nous
pour manifester
la vie du Christ
en nous.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul
arrive
à la présentation
du fruit
de l'Esprit
comme un moyen
!
de fournir
aux Galates
à nous fournir
une base
d'évaluation légitime
pour nous demander
est-ce qu'on est
véritablement convertis?
Est-ce que nous sommes
véritablement associés
à Christ
par la foi?
Est-ce qu'on est
véritablement pardonné
définitivement?
Est-ce qu'on est
véritablement adopté?
Comment évaluer ça?
En évaluant
si nous expérimentons,
si nous manifestons
les fruits de l'Esprit.
Et donc,
les fruits de l'Esprit
ici présentés
n'est pas en train
de négliger
la réalité
d'une bataille
qui reste
avec les restes
de la chair,
des passions de la chair,
mais qui veut
communiquer
que les comportements
prédominants,
la manifestation
prédominante
dans la vie
d'un chrétien,
c'est la vie
des dieux en lui,
la vie du Christ en lui.
C'est le sourire
des dieux
lorsqu'en nous contemplant,
on est en train
de presque
entend parler
comme disait
aux gens,
je vois ma vie
en toi.
Et cette expérience
doit être
une expérience
radicale
que tous
les chrétiens
et que les chrétiens
ont expérimenté
au moment
de leur conversion.
Et cette expérience
doit être
une expérience
permanente
en termes
des capacités
et des progressions.
Donc,
même si dans
notre oscillation
dans les parcours
des fois,
parfois,
en cédant
à la chair,
en résistant
à l'esprit,
on ne peut pas
mener une vie
qui manifeste
ses fruits
de manière harmonique,
une fois,
comme les Galates,
qu'on est exhorté,
la puissance
des dieux
en nous,
elle est tellement
plus élevée
que les forces
de la chair
que nous pouvons
coopérer
légèrement,
infimement
avec le Saint-Esprit
afin de manifester
ces choses.
Et c'est
cette mentalité
qui doit changer
à l'Église.
L'une des hérésies
qui ont les plus
abîmé l'Église
dans nos dernières
générations,
c'est une perspective
de la bataille
contre la chair
qui donne beaucoup
plus d'importance
à la chair,
au péché,
à la tentation,
à Satan,
qu'à notre nouvelle
nature créée par Dieu,
fondée sur l'efficacité
de l'œuvre du Christ
et sponsorisée activement
par la présence
permanente
du Saint-Esprit
en nous.
Ce n'est pas
une bataille
entre forces égales.
Nous sommes
énormément plus
en avantage.
et c'est ça
qui va supprimer
cette mentalité
très victimiste
et ces conceptions
aujourd'hui
qu'on entend parler
des « non,
ils sont des chrétiens,
mais ils sont encore
des chrétiens charnels. »
Ils sont des bébés
spirituels
qui ne sont jamais
en train de grandir.
C'est l'opposé
de la description biblique
de ce qui se passe
avec nous
au moment de la conversion
et ce qui doit marquer
la progression
de notre vie.
Dans ces fruits,
nous avons déjà considéré
plusieurs d'entre eux.
On a considéré
les trois premiers
et ces fruits
sont donc
des évidences
de la vie
du Christ en nous.
À la conversion,
justification,
adoption.
OK ?
Position changée
pour toujours.
Dans la considération
de la manière
dont Dieu
non seulement
nous a déclarés justes,
mais à partir de là
commence à nous rendre justes,
nous sommes devant
les évidences
de la vie du Christ en nous.
C'est un fruit
singulier
car la vie
de tous les chrétiens
c'est une manifestation
harmonique,
inséparable,
symétrique
de toutes ses vertus
ensemble.
En moins d'intensité
ou en plus d'intensité,
mais c'est impossible
d'avoir un grand
déséquilibre
entre ses vertus
car elles se manifestent
toujours ensemble.
Si on regarde
en fruit,
il peut être
moins mûr
ou plus mûr
mais il y a toujours
cet aspect
des proportions,
des symétries.
Sauf s'ils sont
vraiment très disformes
mais en général
c'est comme ça.
Et donc
chez tous les chrétiens
on doit trouver ça.
c'est ça la vérité centrale
pour nous,
tout enfant de Dieu
doit expérimenter
radicalement
ses vertus
ou ses fruits
et manifester
constamment
ses fruits
et manifester
bien sûr
les fruits
en entier.
C'est-à-dire
quelque part
nous sommes
les fruits
de l'esprit.
Vous comprenez ?
C'est un caractère,
c'est une personnalité,
c'est Christ
en nous.
c'est la vie
des journaux.
Et nous avons
considéré
les trois premières
ou la première
triade
si on veut dire
comme ça
qui est
fondationnelle
ou fondamentale.
Qui a plutôt
un état
constant
d'esprit
radical
qui peut supporter
tous les autres fruits,
tous les autres éléments
de ses fruits.
Donc on commence
par l'amour,
on se rappelle très bien,
qui peut être
résumé tout simplement
pour faire la liaison
avec la loi,
avec l'accomplissement
parfait de la loi,
c'est-à-dire
aimer Dieu
sur toutes choses,
les prochains
comme soi-même,
vivre pour
faire Dieu
sourire
et vivre
pour promouvoir
la vie
de mes prochains.
Et donc
c'est cette vie
d'amour
et c'est la conviction
pleine
en ayant compris
l'évangile
que mes demandes
les plus élevées
ou profondes
d'amour
ont déjà été
satisfaites
pleinement
et parfaitement
car Dieu
m'a aimé
d'une telle manière
qu'il m'a donné
son fils,
son fils pour moi.
Donc je peux
réjouir de la source
ultime de l'amour,
Dieu et l'amour
et donc
il n'y a plus
des choses
que je puisse désirer
dans cette vie
qui puissent
augmenter
la sensation
de satisfaction
en termes
d'amour.
Si j'ai
la sensation
qu'il me manque
encore
d'être aimé
ou approuvé
par quelqu'un
en spécifique
c'est plutôt
une indication
d'idolâtrie.
Mais Dieu
m'a aimé.
Tout ce que
je pourrais désirer
de cette vie
c'est déjà
infiniment surmonté
par l'effet
que Dieu m'aime
à tel point
qu'il a envoyé
son fils pour moi.
cet amour
naturellement
produit
l'expérience
suprême
des joies
la sensation
des béatitudes
c'est la joie
du salut
et cette joie
bien sûr
qui commence
par la perception
du fait
qu'on méritait
l'enfer
on a été délivré
de l'enfer
si on est délivré
de la mort
on devrait être
en train
de sauter
des joies
mais non seulement
on a été délivré
de la mort
on a été
positionné
dans la position
la plus élevée
de l'univers
communion
avec Dieu
filiation
des dieux
image des dieux
communion
avec Dieu
en Christ
les chrétiens
et ces phénomènes
et cette personne
qui commence
à sauter
des joies
et qui chante
peu importe
qu'elle soit
en train de traverser
et voilà pourquoi
la paix
vient tout ensuite
c'est fondamentalement
la compréhension
de l'évangile
et cette compréhension
et cette expérience
d'évangile
qui sait
qu'on a été
pardonné
malgré
ce qu'on méritait
souffrir
on s'est vu
un jour
avant la conversion
très anxieux
et très menacé
par la fragilité
de cette vie
par la méchanceté
du monde
par la cruauté
par les guerres
etc
des crises internes
des crises externes
et on a connu
l'évangile de la paix
on a connu
les princes de la paix
qui a fait la réconciliation
avec Dieu
et qui nous a promis
que la réconciliation
avec Dieu
va promouvoir
la réconciliation
avec les mondes
et avec Dieu
et donc on est
en train de
en ayant expérimenté
la paix
la plus importante
qui nous concernait
vis-à-vis
la vie
limitée
envers Dieu
c'est impossible
que ceux
qui ont Dieu
pour père
qui gouvernent
tous les atomes
soient
exagérément
troublés
par les menaces
que cette vie
peut apporter
c'est un état
de sérénité
de l'âme
qui est fondé
sur cette joie
et cet amour
donc cette première
triade
est plutôt
une question
des constances
d'état d'esprit
convaincu
de l'amour
de Dieu
pour moi
débordant
des joies
en parfaite
paix
voici les fondements
du caractère chrétien
dans l'évangile
les trois prochains
vertus
vont parler plus
de comment
cet état d'esprit
se projette
de l'intérieur
vers l'extérieur
dans sa relation
avec les personnes
donc ici
nous voyons
la mention
dans les versetons 2
mais les fruits
de l'esprit
est l'amour
la joie
la patience
la bonté
la bénignité
la fidélité
la douceur
et la tempérance
la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses
donc c'est
cette deuxième
triade
la patience
la bonté
et la bénignité
elles découlent
naturellement
dans nos relations
en fait
cet état d'esprit
amour
joie
et paix
est constaté
dans les relations
de cette personne
avec les autres
par la manifestation
de la patience
de la bénignité
et de la bonté
commençons
à apprécier
quel monument
Dieu est en train
de faire de nous
on regarde
un chrétien
en bonne santé
dans sa relation
avec les personnes
et si on se demande
mais comment
il peut agir
avec une telle patience
comment peut-il agir
avec cette constance
en bénignité
envers les autres
et comment nous pouvons
comprendre
combien bon il est
c'est car
son caractère
est fondé
il a ses goûts
ses jus
ou ses nerfs
qui tient
toutes les choses
ensemble
dans ses fruits
qui est la première triade
amour
joie
paix
ok
et il y a bien sûr
toujours des
interrelations
entre ces éléments
donc
tout enfant d'être
Dieu
doit expérimenter
et manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
et pour nous
aujourd'hui
de manière plus particulière
tout enfant de Dieu
doit manifester
la patience
la bénignité
et la bonté
de l'esprit
vous êtes avec moi
la première chose
qu'on doit faire
comme on a fait
pour les autres vertus
c'est
de comprendre
bibliquement
la nature
de ses vertus
bien sûr
c'est une nature spirituelle
c'est une nature organique
c'est les fruits
de l'esprit
donc ceux qui n'ont pas
l'esprit
des dieux
ne peuvent pas présenter
ces vertus
selon leur compréhension
spirituelle
profonde
on peut observer
quelques manifestations
de ces vertus
dans l'humanité
mais elles ne sont pas
de la même nature
de la même intégrité
que ce que les chrétiens
peuvent
et doivent
manifester
et donc
on commence par la considération
de cette patience
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
un comportement fondé
sur une espèce
d'insécurité
timidité
ou conscience
de fragilité
ceci n'est pas
l'autoprotection
des fois
on a l'impression
que les personnes
sont patientes
mais en réalité
ils sont en train
de souffrir
les coups
des autres
tout simplement
car ils sont
dans l'insécurité
ils ne savent pas
comment réagir
ils préfèrent
quelque part
éviter de réagir
en colère
pour éviter
d'avoir des problèmes
ce n'est pas non plus
les conformismes
aveugles
ou la procrastination
ce n'est pas
tout simplement
une capacité
incroyable
de reporter
les solutions
des problèmes
car on peut
s'évanter
d'être patient
tout simplement
quand on est en train
de rien faire
pour changer les choses
quand on devrait
faire beaucoup de choses
pour chercher
à changer les choses
et cela se projette
aussi bien sûr
par rapport
aux personnes
qui nous entourent
quand on pense
par exemple
on s'évanter
d'être très patient
car on est en train
de supporter
des très mauvais
comportements
de personnes
et les mauvaises
voies d'une personne
parfois les personnes
ont un peu plus
d'ouverture envers nous
car nous
n'avons jamais
eu le courage
de confronter
leur chemin
de manifester
la vraie patience
biblique
qui n'est pas
tout simplement
en train de supporter
en dévenant
complice
de nos mauvais
chemins
mais qui est
patient
envers nous
avec un désir
déterminé
pour améliorer
nos conditions
pour changer
les vrais amours
veulent les biens
voilà pourquoi
ils sont connectés
patience
et bénignité
collés
l'un à l'autre
et donc
ce n'est pas
de supporter
les mauvaises voies
des personnes
tout simplement
et d'attendre
aveuglément
les mieux
ou les changements
sans rien faire
pour changer
ce n'est pas
non plus
la capacité
de ne pas
se laisser
offenser
tout simplement
car par un orgueil
vent
on se considère
plus élevé
que ses attaques
des fois
il y a aussi
cette mentalité
on est tellement
sûr de nous-mêmes
sur des bases
d'orgueil
et on pense
avoir la capacité
d'être patient
mais si on n'était pas
dans une position
si favorable
dans cette dispute
est-ce qu'on s'éventerait
d'être patient
donc
dans aucun de ces cas
nous sommes devant
une patience
définie par la parole
des jeux
les termes
dans l'original
veut dire
macro
timia
qui veut dire
long
ou grand
amplifié
et timia
qui peut représenter
colère
impulsion
ou passion
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc l'essence
littéral
c'est d'avoir
une lenteur
à s'émettre
en colère
c'est la capacité
d'endurer
surtout
les personnes
qui peuvent être
en train de provoquer
notre colère
et c'est la capacité
de supporter
aussi
quelques pressions
de la vie
qui pourraient
nous pousser
à réagir
en colère
si nous sommes devant
ce que la Bible
appelle
les fruits de l'esprit
elle est en train
de manifester
ce que les chrétiens
produisent
naturellement
de soi-même
mais elle est en train
de décrire aussi
comment les chrétiens
réagissent
aux circonstances
c'est-à-dire
les circonstances
ne sont jamais
présentées dans la Bible
comme des excuses
légitimes
par rapport
à la manière
dont on agit
aucune difficulté
qu'on traversera
dans cette vie
ni même
la maladie
car ça fait partie
aussi de cette vie
après la chute
ne peuvent devenir
des raisons
pour nous victimiser
et marcher dans la direction
du péché
l'opposé du fruit de l'esprit
est appelé péché
les œuvres de la chair
mais ici nous sommes
dans la description
c'est-à-dire Paul
quel est l'objectif de Paul ?
vous êtes en train
de vous disputer
à cause d'une doctrine
et vous êtes en train
de manifester
votre colère
même ceux qui ont
la correcte
compréhension doctrinaire
sont en train d'agir
comme des bêtes sauvages
et la question
est-ce que cela
est cohérent
avec la manière
dont Dieu a manifesté
sa patience
envers vous ?
est-ce que cela
est cohérent
avec la déclaration
que vous faites
que la vie du Christ
se manifeste
en vous ?
comment la patience
des dieux
et du Christ
se manifeste
dans vos vies
à travers
particulièrement
les personnes
qui sont les plus
en train de provoquer
votre colère
et des circonstances
qui pourraient
vous tenter
à réagir
de manière passionnée
colérée
c'est pour cela
que nous sommes
devant
des puissances
surnaturelles
pourvues
par l'esprit
c'est cette patience
face aux offenses
et particulièrement
notamment
quand
l'exhortation
à être patient
particulièrement
envers les frères
et sœurs
mais aussi
envers les perdus
c'est dans les cadres
des savoirs
que ça ne devrait pas
être pour les chrétiens
une surprise
d'être persécuté
c'est une hostilité
envers l'évangile
qu'on devrait nous attendre
la même hostilité
qu'amène les Christ
à la croix
et un Christ
qui exerce
sa patience
afin de pouvoir
être
bienveillant
et bénissant
envers ces personnes
et donc
la question
pour nous
c'est
quels sont les constats
envers moi-même
est-ce que j'ai
cette
macro
timia
c'est-à-dire
c'est un schéma
très large
pour moi
jusqu'à ce que je manifeste
la colère
est-ce que j'ai la capacité
d'endurer
d'être sous pression
cette prédisposition
est une prédisposition
attention
interne
engendrée par les saints esprits
fondée sur cette réconciliation
cette paix
faite avec Dieu
qui va
se porter
de manière pratique
envers les autres
sous attaque
patience
mais pas
une patience
sans objectif
pas une patience
sans but
exposé
à souffrir
les attaques
je m'expose
encore plus
en cherchant
sous attaque
à manifester
les biens
vers ces personnes
voilà pourquoi
bénignité
doit être traité
ensemble
quelle est la conception
biblique
de bénignité
ce n'est pas
tout simplement
de faire les biens
par obligation
peut-être
une mobilisation
a été proposée
proposée
et un besoin
apparu
et nous nous sommes
sentis presque obligés
car c'est de la connaissance
des autres
que j'ai eu l'opportunité
ou non
de participer
ce n'est pas
tout simplement
quelque chose
que je vais faire
lorsqu'il y a un besoin
par les frais
ce n'est pas
quelque chose
que l'église
doit sentir
les pasteurs
ou même
nos membres
des familles
ou nos amis
envers nous
comme s'ils devraient
toujours en train
de nous motiver
par certaines bénédictions
ou par quelques menaces
pour qu'on fasse
ces conseils
qu'on devrait faire
c'est cette mentalité
qui n'est pas
la mentalité
des consommateurs
mais c'est une mentalité
des pourvoyeurs
ok
l'église
dans certains moments
de notre vie
peut devenir
un hôpital
légitimement
mais l'église
elle est plutôt décrite
comme une armée
une armée
des services
d'amour
des bénignités
et donc
cette bénignité
n'est pas
de ne pas
faire du bien
selon mes proportions
selon mon agenda
très organisé
selon les proportions
de mon revenu
des fois
l'opportunité
de faire les biens
est là
et on doit
la saisir
en faisant
totale confiance
sur le fait
que ça honore Dieu
ça plaide Dieu
je ne vais pas
consulter même
mon compte bancaire
car si
je peux porter
l'aide
à un frère
qui est dans
un tel besoin
c'est sûr
que mon Père Céleste
qui m'a tout donné
déjà
va pouvoir
je me débrouillerai
plus tard
pour compenser
ces choses
la bénignité
c'est
cette prédisposition
intérieure
à promouvoir
la vie
de l'autre
et voilà
pourquoi
c'est un remède
très efficace
contre l'envie
par exemple
car l'envie
parfois
c'est d'être gêné
avec la prospérité
des autres
la personne
qui a cette bénignité
il sait
qu'il est déjà
la personne
la plus riche
et généreuse
de tout l'univers
car il a été fait
héritier
des dieux
même si on ne touche pas
dans les présents
l'entendance
des richesses
des dieux
on sait
que cela nous attend
il a plu à votre Père Céleste
de vous donner son royaume
faites donc des homoïdes
vous comprenez la logique
la personne qui est
dans la bénignité
elle est très active
très proactif
très résolue
et très déterminée
à bénir
sa plus grande attirance
sans tentation
c'est une opportunité
de faire les biens
difficulté de dire non
aux opportunités
de faire les biens
créer des opportunités
pour faire les biens
c'est cette prédisposition
interne
qui s'éporte
toujours de manière
très pratique
envers l'extérieur
ça ne s'arrête pas
dans l'intentionnalité
de faire les biens
donc ce n'est pas
selon mes proportions
non plus selon
les mérites
ou les proportions
du prochain
remède contre l'envie
je pense que
ses frères
ou ses soeurs
auraient
des meilleures
opportunités
pour l'aider
ils ont déjà assez
peut-être
dans cette ère de sa vie
il est déjà mieux
que moi-même
ce n'est pas la mentalité
qu'on devrait avoir
car les Christ
n'a pas eu
cette mentalité
tout ce qui était
autour de lui
à la croix
était déjà
humainement parlant
dans des circonstances
meilleures que la sienne
mais il était en train
de se donner
de plus en plus
afin de promouvoir
leur propre bien
donc c'est quelque chose
qui parle
de la richesse spirituelle
de la personne même
elle n'est pas
en train d'évaluer
les circonstances extérieures
pour savoir
de quelle manière
il va faire les biens
ce n'est pas non plus
par motivation
d'apparence
Jésus dit
c'est que ta main
droite donne
que la gauche
ne voit même pas
c'est plutôt
et ce n'est pas non plus
une prédisposition sporadique
de temps en temps
j'ai des assauts
des bienveillances
non c'est quelque chose
qui caractérise
tous les vrais chrétiens
tous ceux qui ont
vraiment compris
l'évangile
et qui ont été
connectés à Christ
vous voyez comment
la mentalité
de la théologie
de la prospérité
est à l'inverse
du caractère chrétien
il n'est pas motivé
par une ambition
de prospérité
d'amélioration
des circonstances
dans la vie
d'aujourd'hui
maintenant
c'est plutôt
la certitude
qui crie
sachant qu'il venait
du père
et qu'il revenait
au père
c'est sang
d'une serviette
et il a passé
à laver
les pieds
des disciples
bénédicté
c'est d'être
utile
doux
bienfaisant
bienveillant
c'est l'amour
exprimé
dans la pratique
c'est de promouvoir
les biens
et la prospérité
et surtout
les biens
suprêmes
c'est cette ambition
d'à tout prix
chercher à promouvoir
la conversion
de personnes
devant l'hostilité
de ceux qui nous persécutent
on endure
avec patience
déterminer
non seulement
à souffrir
les coups nécessaires
mais déterminer
à communiquer
l'évangile
attendre
par la patience
des opportunités
pour insister
sur notre amour
donc quel monument
quelle symétrie
c'est aussi
la bonté
et l'ordre
elle est très intéressante
car
ce n'est pas toujours
un ordre logique
mais il y a toujours
une logique dans l'ordre
c'est avec moi
et donc la bonté
selon les termes
original
et je sais que
peut-être dans vos passages
vos traductions
c'est plutôt
bonté avant bénignité
ce qui est plus fidèle
aux termes originaux
c'est plutôt
la bénignité
avant la bonté
et donc il y a
un élan très pratique
entre paix
patience
bénignité
car c'est un objectif
comment
qu'ils vont ensemble
endurer
pour faire les biens
et faire les biens
en endurant
vous êtes avec moi ?
et là c'est juste
une connexion
d'intégrité
très riche
car c'est quoi
la bonté
la parole de Dieu
elle nous dit
Jésus lui-même
le dit
aux jeunes riches
!
quand il est fait
faire les biens
pour la bonne motivation
faire un bien parfait
pour la gloire
des dieux
tous nos bienfaits
sont tachés
des corruptions
et donc c'est intéressant
car la bonté
n'est pas tout simplement
une bonté
apparente
car des
des bonnes personnes
entre guillemets
l'enfer
il sera rempli
c'est pas
l'apparence
d'être une bonne personne
qui peut mêler
les personnes
au paradis
c'est pas
une bonté
apparente
à la surface
elle certainement
apparaîtra
à la surface
mais cette bonté
elle est peut-être
celle qui est plus liée
à la conception
de l'unité
de ses fruits
c'est quoi
cette bonté ?
est quelque chose
qui est dirigée
à la source
de l'être
elle n'est pas
superficielle
comme celle
des pharisiens
qui semblaient être
en train de pratiquer
la bonté
et qui sonnaient
les trompettes
lorsqu'ils faisaient
un bienfait
mais
elle ne peut pas
ne pas se manifester
à l'extérieur
par la patience
et par la bénédicté
car d'abord
et avant tout
c'était un changement
du coeur
c'est la régénération
c'est la pureté
du coeur
c'est la bonté
on était mauvais
un mauvais arbre
on est devenu
un bon arbre
c'est par la bonté
en termes
de la pratique
de la bénédicté
qu'on vient de voir
et c'est pour dire
nous ne pouvons
qu'il n'est pas
être patient
et bénin
bienveillant
car nous sommes bons
Dieu a changé
notre nature
dès la source
toute cette sémétrie
de toutes ces vertus
ont eu lieu
en nous
les moments
de notre conversion
ont été convaincus
qu'on était mauvais
méchant
mort
rébelle
ennemi
de Dieu
Dieu a opéré
un tel
grand
et radical
changement
dans notre nature
que nous sommes
désormais bons
et même si
nous ne sommes pas
parfaitement bons
c'est cet aspect
des droitures
d'intégrité
des cohérences
des symétries
qui nous font comprendre
que selon
!
la compréhension
et la cohérence
de l'évangile
qui nous a sauvés
c'est impossible
d'être patient
sans être bénin
c'est impossible
d'être dans la joie
et dans l'amour
sans être doux
c'est impossible
d'avoir expérimenté
cette paix
cette réconciliation
avec Dieu
sans agir
avec de soeur
c'est impossible
d'avoir
expérimenté
tous les sacrifices
du Christ
pour me sauver
et ne pas
m'efforcer
pour exercer
une maîtrise
de moi-même
qui ne représente pas
un mépris
envers
les souffrances
du Christ
à la croix
si
mon manque
de maîtrise
de moi
afin que Christ
souffre à la croix
même si
je ne peux pas
agir de manière
rétroactive
pour diminuer
ces souffrances
à la croix
je peux désormais
avec la force
du Saint-Esprit
faire des efforts
pour honorer
sa moi-pour-moi
maîtrise de moi
pour la cause
du Christ
pour son amour
et donc
cette bonté
elle parle
de cette intégrité
c'est comme
si elle était
dans cette triade
la deuxième triade
les fondements
qui vont nous projeter
envers les relations
des manières
à être patient
et d'exercer
constamment
la bénignité
voilà pourquoi
c'est pas une bonté
fragmentée
je suis un bon
professionnel
mais c'est vrai
que parfois
je manque à la maison
moi l'objectif
c'est d'être bon
envers les pauvres
mais pas forcément
envers d'autres
qui commettent
l'injustice sociale
c'est tout simplement
d'être bon
c'est pas une question
des proportions
voilà pourquoi
Christ dit
personne n'est bon
sinon un
qui est Dieu
c'est une question
qualificatrice
et pas une question
quantificative
Dieu est saint
Dieu est bon
Dieu est pur
Dieu est parfait
voilà pourquoi
aucun être
corrompu
ne peut
s'approcher
des dieux
qui est décrit
dans sa sainteté
dans sa pureté
comme cet amour parfait
qui est comme le soleil
qui va tout consommer
c'est une question
de pureté
aucune impureté
ne peut résister
à la force du soleil
voilà ce que Dieu
dit à Moïse
enlève les sandales
de tes pieds
car il était en train
de s'approcher
du Dieu
qui se manifeste
par cette flamme
des totales
santé
des totales puretés
et même si on n'est pas
parfaitement saint
après la conversion
on est radicalement
changé dans la nature
et c'est une caractéristique
de tous les vrais chrétiens
cette capacité
d'expérimenter
ces élans
envers toutes ces vertus
car Dieu nous a changés
depuis le cœur
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que nous devons avoir
cette compréhension
mais il faut que ça
aussi connecter
à la racine
et donc
pour vivre
expérimenter
préserver
cultiver
manifester
la patience
la bénévité
la bonté de l'esprit
nous devons
surtout
rester
connecté
à la racine
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire
par là
si on est un fruit
dont la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
nous porte
à la manifestation
de ces vertus
ces vertus
ne peuvent qu'être
vécues
expérimentées
ou se produire
en nous
car
elles sont
connectées
à Christ
et c'est surtout
Dieu
qui s'est présent
dans sa parole
comme en étant
les possesseurs
absolus
de ces vertus
par exemple
quand on prend
l'Epsom 103
qu'on a considéré
l'entre eux
nous voyons
cette description
d'un Dieu
qui exerce
sa patience
envers nous
non
comme un signe
de sa complicité
envers nos péchés
mais comme une opportunité
qu'il nous donne
pour nous répentir
et embrasser
l'opportunité du pardon
qui lui-même va pouvoir
par sa bénignité
donc
les versets 11
pardon
les versets 7
les versets 8
allez
l'éternel
est compatissant
et miséricordieux
lent
à la colère
vous êtes avec moi
lent
à la colère
ok
l'onganimité
c'est d'avoir
un visage
large
donc
quand on est devant
nos enfants
c'est comme si
ils devraient faire
infiniment plus
de ce qu'ils font
avant que notre visage
change
l'homme à la colère
est riche
en bonté
il ne conteste pas
sans cesse
il ne garde pas
sa colère à toujours
il ne nous traite pas
selon nos péchés
il ne nous punit
pas selon nos iniquités
car autant
les cieux
sont élevés
au-dessus de la terre
autant
sa miséricorde
est grande
pour ceux
qui les craignent
autant
l'orient
est éloigné
de l'occident
autant
il est loin
de nous
notre transgression
vous voyez la croix ici
cieux
terre
orient
occident
et ces deux aspects
un dieu
qui pardonne
nos transgressions
et qui éloignent
qui pardonne
et qui purifie
autant
pardon
verset 13
comment perdre
la compassion
de ses enfants
l'éternel
la compassion
de ceux
qui les craignent
car il connaît
notre structure
et se souvient
que nous sommes
de la poussière
vous voyez
combien
différent
est la perspective
biblique
même dans l'ancien testament
de ces dieux tyrans
qui est très intéressé
à voir nos manquements
notre mauvaise performance
pour nous virer
comme un esclave
et un dieu
qui a les grands responsables
de manifester
car il est bon
car il est fondé
sur sa bonté
car son amour
envers nous
ses bienfaits
ne dépendent pas
de nos comportements
ils dépendent
exclusivement
de quelque chose
qu'il est
de son caractère
bon
c'est à cause
de sa bonté
qu'il agit
avec bienveillance
avec patience
envers nous
comprenez
c'est donc
une vertu
en vertu
des dieux
quand on voit aussi
Ephésiens chapitre 2
pardon
verset 1
la description
de notre condition avant
ennemi
c'est nous
qui étions en train
de provoquer
la colère des dieux
constamment
donc
et vous
vous étiez mort
par vos offenses
et par vos péchés
dans lesquels
vous marchiez autrefois
selon les siècles présents
selon les princes
de la puissance
de l'air
de l'esprit
qui agit maintenant
dans les enfants
de la rébellion
nous tous aussi
nous étions de leur nombre
et nous vivions autrefois
selon les combattis
de notre chair
accomplissant des volontés
de la chair
et des pensées
et nous étions
par nature
enfants des colères
comme les autres
tous
c'est pour dire
nous les juifs
comme les autres
les païens
enfants des colères
c'était la nature
l'homme par nature
est dans cette condition
devant Dieu
en train de provoquer
la colère de Dieu
et qu'est-ce qu'on voit
dans la suite
mais comme certains
d'entre vous
avez un petit reste
de bonté
qui vous a permis
de choisir
pour l'évangile
ou pour Dieu
Dieu en anticipant
les faits
que certains
allaient accepter
l'évangile
vous a pardonné
non
mais Dieu
c'est un contraste
avec
toutes nos contributions
qui n'étaient
qu'est-ce que péché
et la seule raison
que Dieu va trouver
pour nous bénir
pour exercer sa patience
toutes les sources
des bienfaits
des dieux envers nous
des patiences
ne dépendent pas
de notre performance
dépendent du fait
qui Dieu est
et de qui il est
regardez bien
mais Dieu
qui est riche
en miséricorde
donc c'est sa richesse
des caractères
en soi-même
à cause du grand amour
dont il nous a aimé
qui a décidé
de placer envers nous
son amour
par des raisons
qui nous échappent
car quand on voit
les raisons
de ce qu'on pourrait
provoquer un Dieu
ce n'est qu'il y a de la colère
mais Dieu
qui est riche
en miséricorde
à cause du grand amour
dont il nous a aimé
à cause de sa bonté
nous a même
même quand nous étions
morts par nos offenses
rendu la vie
avec Christ
c'est par grâce
qu'il vous a été sauvé
et attention
patience
envers la repentance
grâce pour la conversion
mais remarquez bien
la bénignité
sans limite
ce n'est pas
de nous donner
les minimums nécessaires
et il nous a ressuscités
avec lui
et nous a fait asseoir
dans les lieux célestes
en Christ Jésus
c'est là notre destinée
absolue
aucune chose
ne peut empêcher
un vain chrétien
d'y finir
car nous sommes là
déjà
selon la conception biblique
saboter envers nous
en Jésus Christ
car c'est par la grâce
que vous êtes sauvés
par les moyens de la foi
cela ne vient pas de vous
c'est les dons des dieux
ce n'est pas par les oeuvres
afin que personne
ne se glorifie
car nous sommes
son ouvrage
ayant été
en Jésus Christ
ayant été créé
pour les bonnes oeuvres
qui Dieu a préparés
d'avance
afin que nous les pratiquions
nous sommes son ouvrage
c'est Dieu
qui nous a créés
pour vivre ça
c'est Dieu
qui nous a créés
pour manifester
les fruits
et clairement
Dieu
ou à Dieu
crédité
cette considération
mais bien sûr
qu'à Christ
crédité aussi
je n'ai pas
les temps
de traverser
tous les passages
mais
lorsqu'il Christ
va exhorter
les disciples
à traiter
les mâles
avec les biens
il va associer
ces commandements
au fait
que nous sommes
fils des dieux
soyez donc parfait
comme votre père
céleste
et parfait
soyez donc bon
ok
si vous êtes bon
comme votre père
vous marchez
dans la bénignité
et dans la patience
mais c'est surtout
à la croix
bien sûr
que nous voyons
la plus grande manifestation
des dieux
en Christ
ou la manifestation
directe du Christ
qui est
à la une
l'expression
la plus élevée
de la patience
divine
car Dieu
a laissé
impunis
les péchés
commis
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
punis
pour ceux qui seront
sauvés à la croix
et jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
!
à l'enfer
ok?
mais aucun péché
ne sera jamais
laissé impunis
donc la patience
des dieux
ne doit jamais
être confondue
avec la légitimité
ou la permissivité
des dieux
ou la complicité
avec nos péchés
que ça soit clair
mais la patience
des dieux
elle se révèle
car jusqu'à
la venue du Christ
Dieu a exercé
une patience
envers toute l'humanité
depuis la chute
d'Adenaïe
pour nous donner
l'opportunité
de rédemption
à notre race
mais à la croix
en elle-même
on voit dans tous
les parcours du Christ
combien d'oppositions
d'attaques
d'hostilité
il a enduré
cracher
humilier
Dieu lui-même
Dieu les fils
l'exemple suprême
des patience
comme un brebis
moins
si nous disons
avoir pour Christ
notre sauveur
notre caractère
est associé à Christ
dans quel niveau
cette racine
devrait
pourvoir
la puissance
pour qu'on soit patient
blasphémé
délué
humilié
frappé
puni
et les seules choses
qui sortent de sa bouche
sont les bénédictions
et il continue
de faire les biens
il continue
d'accomplir son oeuvre
quelles sont ses déclarations
il pardonne
les voleurs à la croix
il demande à Dieu
en terre salle
pardonne-leur
ils ne savent pas
ce qu'ils font
et il dit
tout est accompli
n'oublions pas
les pressoirs
car cette notion
d'endurer
avec patience
elle est remarquable
lorsqu'il est en train
de transpirer du sang
au geste
le pressoir
les pressoir
d'olive
trois fois
il essaye de prier
car pendant trois fois
pour tirer les jus
de l'olive
elle devrait souffrir
la pression
quelle patience
quelle endurance
pour être
béné
pour faire les bains
et pourquoi
il l'a fait
pour aucune raison
en dehors de lui-même
pour aucune chose
en nous
qui pourrait le provoquer
tout simplement
par le fait
qu'il est
bon
il se prend
de richesses
il n'est pas en train
de regarder en nous
autour de nous
des raisons pour nous aimer
comme quelqu'un a déjà dit
il regarde
au-dedans de soi-même
et il trouve
dans sa bonté parfaite
ce qu'il faut
en termes de motivation
pour déverser sur nous
la plus grande
remontée de l'univers
nous tirer
de la misère
de péché d'un côté
et nous positionner
et de nous mettre
dans la position
la plus élevée
et la plus glorieuse
qu'on puisse imaginer
cette perfection
des dieux
qui se développe en nu
par les fruits de l'esprit
et qui est très efficace
contre les oeuvres
de la chair
et donc on va constater
dans le dimanche prochain
cette efficacité
contre les oeuvres
de la chair
cette relation
avec
les fruits de l'esprit
dans son ensemble
et pour aujourd'hui
qu'on sache très bien
que pour manifester
pour préserver
ses vertus
de la patience
de la bénéguilité
et de la bonté
on doit rester
connecté
à la race
à Christ
dans son évangile
qui révèle
les caractères parfaits
aussi
des dieux
les pères
et de la bonté